vous avez passé la semaine à taper le
nom des responsables politiques les plus
mignons plus le mot sextape dans google
pas de panique nous pendant ce temps là
on a surveillé la vie de vos people
préférés
voici tout ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine et on commence avec loana qui
une fois encore sur instagram fait
parler d'elle avec un bad buzz cette
fois ci c'est son ex compagnon frédéric
cauvin qui est accusé par closer d'avoir
frappé la starlette selon les
indiscrétions du magazine il se serait
introduit chez elle à deux reprises et
aurait levé la main sur elle à l'arrivée
de la police de la drogue aurait été
retrouvée chez loana
des accusations que son ex dément le
soir où ça a dérapé loana n'avait pas
l'air dans son état normal
elle parlait sans arrêt devenu parano je
me suis énervé et elle a appelé les
flics en leur demandant de me faire
partir de son côté loana affirme que
toute cette histoire est un fake
n'écoutez pas ces diffamations
mensongères qui n'ont lieu d'être que
pour faire du mal et détruire c'est une
image difficile que celle d'elton john
au bord des larmes à auckland lors d'un
concert de sa tournée dimanche dernier
l'artiste de 72 ans a craqué incapable
de sortir une note en plein milieu d'une
chanson je ne peux pas chanter je viens
de perdre ma voix il faut que j'y aille
je suis vraiment désolé escorté en
coulisses par les membres de son staff
le chanteur a fait savoir qu'il aurait
besoin de quelques jours de repos pour
se remettre d'une pneumonie atypique
heureusement sans gravité dont il est
atteint elle est l'une des actrices
françaises les plus connues au monde et
maintenant en plus d'avoir du succès
elle va sentir bon marion cotillard
vient de décrocher un contrat avec la
maison de haute couture chanel pour être
l'égérie du mythique parfum chanel
numéro 5
elle succède donc à catherine deneuve
carole bouquet nicole kidman ou encore
lily rose depp comme représentant
officiel de ce parfum iconique
à côté de toi c'est le nom du nouveau
tube des [ __ ] 2020 un titre composé
par le groupe boulevard des airs et le
chanteur tibs cette semaine la troupe a
dévoilé le clip de ce nouvel hymne
[Musique]
un nouveau clip avec quelques petits
nouveaux le concert des [ __ ] sera
diffusé le 6 mars prochain sur tf1
et on termine ce tour des people avec
madonna qui est au bout du rouleau la
star de 61 ans qui depuis un mois est
blessé au genou et à la hanche n'arrête
pas d'annuler concert sur concert les
médecins insistent pour que je prenne un
jour de repos après chaque spectacle
c'est un miracle si j'ai tenu jusque là
la superstar qui a été aperçue il ya
quelques jours se déplaçant avec une
canne visiblement très affaibli il n'y a
pas à dire dur dur d'être retraité et
voilà le tour de l'actu people s'est
terminée apparition du plus gros
consommateur d'autobronzant depuis
l'invention de bernard montiel dans 3 2
[Applaudissements]
et malheureusement la pas très très
heureux car ce qui serait 80 qu'elle
fait la une des magazines fait toujours
pour des mauvaises nouvelles on parle de
loana puisque selon le magazine closer
on embrasse luc angevert caisse en
vacances cette semaine lui février
dernier loana aurait appelé la police
après que son ex donc frédéric cauvin on
frise iman pas son aide qui sont encore
ensemble les violenter chez elle alors
il faut savoir qu effectivement lui se
défend en disant pas du tout on était
tous les deux dans un état un peu second
elle est tombée c'est comme ça qu'elle
est qu'elle a été et qu'elle avait des
ecchymoses sur le visage elle est un peu
revenue sur ce qu'elle a dit mais après
on verra après parce qu'ils trouvent que
guillaume l'a eu au téléphone donc on a
des vrais vraie info ce qui est plus
inquiétant évidemment c'est que selon le
parisien encore ils ont découvert donc
chez elle alors des delà de
malheureusement des produits stupéfiants
donc selon le parisien bien sûr une
cinquantaine de cachets d'ecstasy ce
gigantesque quelques résidus de cocaïne
est ce qu'on appelle 150 g de flacq
alors je sais pas ce que c'était on est
à regarder sur internet c'est ce qu'on
appelle la drogue du cannibale c'est une
drogue et plusieurs cas aux états unis
où les gens deviennent un peu fou
violent et mordent des gens et même jeu
se bouffent entre eux à ccc les drogues
de synthèse tout ça qu'on achète sur
internet pas cher bon tout ça est une
catastrophe
les mauvaises nouvelles nouvelle voie là
et on va évidemment demander à loana
devenu aujourd'hui elle a un peu hésité
elle voulait pas mais les guillaume au
téléphone qu'est ce qu'elle dit
guillaume
elle dit que tout est faux oui dans les
buts
elle dit que je la crois si elle la juge
lacroix et puis si c'est pas vrai c'est
pas grave mais en tout cas elle me dit
qu'elle est fatiguée que la drogue c'est
faux ouais hôpital c'est faux oui il est
venu chez elle et qu'elle veut surtout
qu'on la laisse tranquille mais je vois
juste une question pour ceux qui savent
ce qu'on a parce que chaque elle a fait
une petite vidéo instagram pour dire que
tout voilà tout allait bien regarder
parce que même la vidéo pardon est un
petit peu chelou
ouais cool ou alors comme sa chute en
forme qui vous viennent elle elle paraît
bizarre sur le truc mais n'aurait pas
abîmer c'est ça qu'elle voulait montrer
bon bref pas guillaume et 10000 filtre
qu'on avait en tout cas le problème
c'est que dès qu'on parle de loi n'a
malheureusement c'est pour des mauvais
choix et manger une question que je me
dis aussi à sébastien moi je lis le
parisien et un rapport de la police
alors qu'ils soient battues ou pas ça
j'étais pas dans la pièce mais je peux
pas croire que la police est déposée de
la drogue dans les tiroirs pour
provoquer ce qu'ils ont à [ __ ] la
police de deux ils vont pas piéger
louana c'est pas rien si sébastien sait
pas c'est totalement vrai cette histoire
d'autant plus que nous on a eu son petit
ami frédéric au téléphone et qui nous a
évidemment confirmer toutes ces infos et
que lui pour le coup dit que non
seulement ils se sont battus mais pas
fin que lui aussi a pris des coups et
que et que comme ils étaient
effectivement enfin lui dit que c'est
elle qui était sous drogue ça a vite
dégénéré donc elle ne peut pas tout
démenti via des bus depuis le début il
fait ça il lui a fait vendre son
appareil au musée pas le prophète de lui
moi ce que je veux savoir ce qu'elle dit
que tout est faux tellement raison de le
dire mais revenue vous aurez toute sa
parole vas-y sébastien parce que tu la
connais tous les cas moi je les ai
connus ensemble il ya quelques années
j'ai connu loana avant lui
pendant qu'elle était avec lui et après
lui tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que loana son état psychique
psychologique et ce qui peut se passer
dans sa vie dépend de la personne qui
l'entouré en l'occurrence et avec lui
c'est souvent le problème
elle avait quitté elle était repartie
chez sa mère tout allait pour le mieux
là depuis
la rentrée elle est revenue à paris est
tout seul il revient dans l'histoire il
ya des problèmes je suis pas super
étonnez donc moi l'histoire j'ai
tendance plutôt à y croire mais c'est
normal qu'elle lll veuille se défendent
de ça il y en a peut-être marre de faire
la une de l'actualité avec ce genre de
problème j'entends bien oui pardon alors
encore une info là et puis la part de
suzac tous les deux beaucoup bossé sur
le dossier oui quand tu dis elle fait la
une de la fois en même temps quand elle
est sur twitter et notamment elle a eu
des échanges avec frédéric ovins sûr
pour les réseaux sociaux ils vont pas de
main morte à parce que lui l'a traitée
de vieille vache et cetera donc c'est un
peu eux aussi qui s'explique on va
passer par là mais j'ai tellement peur
que tout ça finisse mal dès qu'on parle
d'elle pour dealer de drogue de violence
d'alcool et tout ça a déjà failli finir
voilà j'aimerais j'aimerais assez déjà
tenté de se suicider absolument bien sûr
où il a été très bon
catherine et ensuite mathieu est là
fonctionnement qui est toujours le même
elle nie toujours et elle confirme
quelques mois quelques années après moi
j'ai un exemple avec elle très concret
quand je dirigeais un magazine télé et
quelques années interview d'elle auprès
d'un des journalistes
elle nous révèle pour une des premières
fois ses problèmes d'addiction voilée
révèle évidemment on aime on le met dans
le papier et on titres là-dessus
voilà une grosse info elle dément elle
ne manque pas de chance pour elle on
avait enregistré donc le découplage
chérissez même gentil mais l'arc s'est
passé bien toi qui parles points et elle
confirme donc luan à l'import et la sica
la vérité qui dépend non seulement des
gens avec qui elle est mais également de
son étage dit ça on aime beaucoup ce que
vous dites et voilà oui on a pas de
doute malheureusement sur le fait que
alors je mets le conditionnel parce que
les émissions de télé mais c'est pas
beaucoup de doutes sur les fesses que
tata ce qui serait intéressant de
comprendre maintenant effectivement
c'est qu'elle s'entoure bien ce serait
de l'aider oui d'accord les dix mois ça
fait des années que j'entends dire il
faut que cette fille soit aidée par
quelqu'un le problème c'est que pour
être aidé pour que ça fonctionne faut
avoir envie de s'en sortir et je ne suis
pas certain que loana est vraiment envie
que ça sentira lettres énormes et on l'a
filmé ya longtemps ça allait très très
bien parce qu'elle avait sa mère avec sa
mère on l'avait filmée dans le sud en
effet pendant l'été dans le sud
eric tu en as jamais d'ailleurs bien
ensemble a noté que son emballage
m'installe dans le 8e jeu revient à
paris bon là il ya un petit problème
moi j'ai tendance à lyon c'est pas un
petit problème 150 g a passé au crible
de couture campagne vient avec le
journal le parisien ne s'est pas c'est
pas un site internet de fait connu mais
ce que je sais c'est quoi le rapport de
la police la police à dry a caché la
drogue pour piéger loi non mais c'est
vrai que vous l'avez vu le rapport de la
police
le parisien n'avait rien à vue il avait
donc
donc oui c'est sais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas du feq voilà un petit mot
parce que vous les connaissez vous avez
parlé de jolis dire simplement elle est
bien chaque fois qu'elle est avec sa
mère oui et quand sa mère
c'est tellement qu'elle est loin de
paris et qu'elle est loin de paris très
bien on va on va où tu voudras me répond
c'est ce que le parisien en fait à des
bonnes infos donc avec la police moi je
sais que quand j'avais eu un souci dans
une boîte de nuit
le lendemain ça avait été dans le
parisien parce qu'ils avaient abandonné
sa police et ses vrais bas le rapport de
police amanpour rapport de police papa
pierre jean iii calm enquêter sur la
police que j'aime beaucoup
après il
l'entièreté du rapport pour la presse
yves 18h26 sa part au parquet non mais
c'est comme ça moi j'ai été cambriolé
ils ont mis six mois d'enquêté une
déclaration à la presse people bon ça on
sait pas d'où ça vient ça le sujet en
tout cas les amis juste encore un petit
bout on va faire rappeler dessus elton
john je sais pas qui a des infos ou pas
que c'est grave ou pas sa pneumonie on a
vu que sur scène et s'est levé il a dit
il a arrêté son cancer
moi j'aurais dit arrêté il a arrêté son
concert mais il avait déjà fait
quasiment 70 % des chansons de rester
huit blessés c'est grave parce que c'est
l'artiste solo qui a donné le plus de
concerts de ceux de tout le temps en
fait il a fait 5500 concerts depuis 1970
est la seule fois le seul concert qui ne
va pas finir c'est celui là dans ma
psychologiquement je pense que y'a voilà
est-ce que c'est pas un peu la fin pour
ceux qui n'ont pas vu leur garde et
c'est sa dernière tournée
effectivement ce que touche en sait
qu'on a un public qu'on mérite personne
ne l'a vu et alors qu'il restait huit
chansons oui en soi c'est un artiste
qu'on aime qu'on admire et il se montre
naturel il a lutté il est venu sur sa
faim sur l'un dans la salle de concert
on est toujours dans le ça s'est passé
cette semaine marion cotillard là c'est
chic à les amis c'est chic égérie de
chanel numéro 5 c'est la marque elle
même qui a annoncé la nouvelle à
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux
elle devrait apparaître dans la nouvelle
campagne de la marque de luxe dans les
prochains mois alors aucune information
concernant sa rémunération n'a filtré
mais nous évidemment on a enquêté c'est
ici que ça se passe à bloquer les infos
merci à plein deux reprises à chaque
fois après l'émission en est fier voilà
effectivement égérie chanel la la c'est
chic guillaume c'est à vous qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire dessus toujours qu'on
parle de nabila de cette machine de
l'émission l'a fait sigma angotti
c'est la première fois qu'elle va prêter
sa ensemble son image à un parfum
ce qui est intéressant dans l'histoire
de chanel numéro cinq a un parfum
mythique vous savez il y avait on avait
présentée cinq échantillons à coco
chanel et elle avait fait un deux trois
quatre cinq pizzas sera celui-là et
c'est devenu numéro 5 de cabochons le
bouchon deux élus jong ii le truc c'est
en fait vu duo la place dans de brefs à
paris est pas le seul il ya toujours eu
des femmes qui ont pu en prêter leur
image pour un numéro 5 les plus chics 1
2 9 paradis et ce à des américaines et
autres le seul garçon qui est qu'ils
aient jamais prêté son image pour un
parfum pour femmes
c'est brad pitt carré prêté son image
pour exactement 7 millions de dollars
juste pauvre pas voilà pourquoi pour
s'être en ping campagne là pardon je
crois que pendant très longtemps c'est
plus qu'aujourd'hui c'était le parfum le
plus vendu dans le monde
c est ce que quelqu'un c'est comme ça on
en rêve d'un faux téléspectateurs
combien va toucher marion cotillard pour
pour cette campagne de pub
moi j'ai comme un faux on parle de 6
millions de dolla d'euros web après ce
que j'ai entendu aussi ses gigantesques
en angleterre qu'elle parle un oscar
sarah cj gracieux et on a les deux
autres là c'est la pomme pardon pour tom
et lila c'est la partie intellectuelle
[Musique]
tu rigoles mais en attendant des deux là
je suis baissé leur moi ok c'est bon les
amis nantais auteur conteur quotas
[Applaudissements]
les yeux dans les yeux ouais je sais pas
bien mais tu es bourdin pagaille sur la
bourre mieux coûta ticket de métro h
était pas bon très bien donc la jet
bourdin et la deuxième est ce que tu as
vraiment inscrits au bouquin alors j'ai
pas travailler avec une dame qu'est ce
que tu as écrit n'a donc se voir donc tu
l'as pas écrire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut revenir sur ma un coacheur woot
eut tiré la couverture à tours nord
côtière et magali berda par l'om et
rennes en commun géré le chiffre marion
cotillard 2,6 millions en euros et
appauvrissante cohérent parce que moi
j'avais une info concernant j'ai une
bonne chaîne qui avait signé avec une
autre marque célèbre serein pour une
crème et qui avait touché 12 millions de
dollars pour deux ans pour voir que vous
c'est beau parent et beaucoup auraient
public fait ou cd campagne mondiale 1
s'est pas vu c'est un des pilotes a rien
fait ouais petite info intéressante vous
remarquerez que ces femmes là quand elle
signe avec ses marques la leur âge ce
filtre pourquoi parce qu'il ya un
phénomène d'identification elles vont
aussi bien aux côtés à 44 ans j'ai une
bonne chaîne à 40 ans c'est déjà
intéressant pour les marques service des
femmes qui ont de l'argent quand 40 ans
mais ce coup qui veulent identifier à
des femmes qui sont magnifiques et qui
reste supposément belle aux imprimés
magistrature lui nice et pas 6 millions
au total ces six millions à la signature
du contrat
mais après vous avez tout ce qui est
droit à l'image mais non pendant des
années déjà les droits d'image cependant
pas en train d'assister la première
connerie de me tuer le temps
[Applaudissements]
non pas de carrière j'ai fait la 317e
total oui mais pas savoir la signature
du contrat combien de temps va durer si
elle va être conduit toutes les
campagnes qui s'arrête
il ya des copains comment dire un quart
le plus grand parent enfant de vous de
ce groupe parce que fais tu es moi j'ai
quand même des infos de la beauce et
tout ça c'est un forfait et au total
elle a touché cette somme 2 signant
devant quels que soient les verts que
soit la durée n'est absolument et céline
amis focus se porte pas sur le sujet
puisque bien que de faire ça tout y'a
quand même assez revient du mot
populaire madonna matin de 61 ans voilà
se déplace désormais avec une canne
le problème c'est que là on a dû donc
annulé des dates de concert
effectivement ce qui est invisible pour
les matines je remonterai c'est qu'on
annule des dates de concerts dans
captain jack je vois qu'ils sont tous
tristes et puis sur instagram il ya deux
ou trois jours
hop on la voit comme ça regardez ma mère
est là
regardez oui mais sans dec et ça c'est
100 m alors je défends bien c'est le
médecin est venu les dates de concerts
mais c'est vrai que je peux comprendre
que pour les gens alors est ce que
quelqu'un a des infos parce que tout ça
fait beaucoup parler quand même moi je
jouais juste sur mathieu lajoie ya un
truc si vous voulez faire plus jeunes
fauves ou s'entourer de gens plus âgés
c'est pour ça que vous aller au ski et
guillaume c'est pas une info mais c'est
mais je vais jamais alors de table avec
une question effectivement madonna ça
qu'est né son mec j'adore au ridicule
dont déjà la can est ce que quelqu'un a
des infos après de la can de son mec et
ensuite de contenus concert qui arrive à
paris très bientôt a mis en effet elle
alors il y aurait eu mon guytou tendant
mais oui en effet elle elle a des
problèmes ça va pas bien
ça n'empêche pas de danse et elle peut
pas danser pendant des heures et des
heures
en fait il faut qu'elle fasse deux
concerts sur trois ouais absolument
jamais eu autant de concerts de suite
donc c'est les deux depuis depuis des
années depuis calade depuis qu'elle est
toute petite elle elle c'était une
danseuse est là elle a abîmé son corps
est aujourd'hui à 61 ans est là elle a
le corps qui est un peu bancal
absolument sachez qu'elle arrive à paris
elle fera donc à paris deux camps
accords signés en ce moment là dès
samedi la voilà il reste quelques places
et à mi mars et à chaque fois il y aura
deux concerts et repos de concert et en
tout cas pas respecté c'est quand même
courageux parce que privilégie des
petites salles donc on le voit alors on
a du ridicule pour sébastien mais peut
être face on ne peut pas faire autrement
maintenant que de faire des petites
salles et pis je sais pas c'est quoi
l'histoire avec ces mecs de de 25 ans
parce que c'est pas la faute au regard
de la photo voilà et alors c'est que
vous avez des infos ou es ce que vous
avez combien de temps qu'elle avait que
ça fait un an et ça fait cinq ans
qu'elle le connaît mais elle avait déjà
fait ça avant mais on a l'impression que
tout ce que tout ce qu'elle fait c'est
un peu provoc caisses assura la cage ça
devient ça devient et devient ridicule
ben non on voit qu'on va il faut qu'elle
assume son âge maintenant
stop un jeune c'est ridicule s'est parée
des couleurs
j'ai pas dit que les armes il a été là
j'aurais évidemment fait des bisous
c'est normal mais évidemment x1 question
avec un jeune soir unis quand j'ai dit
que tout ce qui a fait commence à
devenir ridicule parce qu'on a
l'impression que tout ce qu'elle fait
elle le fait pour le buzz pour moins de
temps à arriver culinat fait un petit
peu la fée carabosse qui se tape un
lutin guillaume a raison et pendant des
années il ya des mecs moche qui sont
tapés des femmes jeunes va maintenant
une femme plus âgée qui se tape un jeune
cédric fait ce qu'elle veut mais météo
donc la qualificative mans c'est un
artifice aujourd'hui comme une bande ou
un moment donné mais sur laquelle elle
est pas mal elle peut pas faire plus de
deux concerts parce que elle donne
beaucoup justement voilà des plus jeunes
et la très gros problèmes aux genoux
effectivement de son mac savait
qu'amazon si la bête même si c'est un
toy boy
ah non pardon j'aurais bien aimé réussir
un homme en carrière avec quelqu'un
est-ce que vous avez vous trouvé ça vous
vous adorez pourquoi vous adorez pour
que j'avais un petit fils adoré je vais
l'adoré
demandez-moi isabelle maincion si je te
dis pourquoi tu aimes mages m pascal à
61 ans qu'elle est belle et qu'elle se
fout d'être malade malade elle continue
elle conquiert elle est la france que
pour vous aussi laissez là céline dion
française aux centurions qu'on vote
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parrainée par aide et 2 mais l'autre
vers sont plus françaises les jeunes ça
court vite mais les vieux chemins
vraiment un truc très drôle avant qu'on
arrête avec madonna si les objets là
vous savez qu'il ya donc toutes les
dates de concerts qui vont être à paris
donc tout mon avis dont à peine poste
qui ont déjà leur billet voilà les
choses qui sont interdites à l'entrée du
du concert mais appareils photos quels
qu'ils soient enregistreurs quoi quels
qu'ils soient nourriture boissons
canettes bouteilles bourde ordinateur
portable alors j'aime bien les armes les
armes à feu les bourgs ont passé à terre
au cas où quelqu'un s'était intéressée
voilà venir les fleurs et portant un
masque clouté chaînes cloutées ou
ceinture à clous les vêtements signes
extérieurs de langage explicite de
discriminant les messages les drapeaux
c'est hallucinant et une dernière vidéo
vous montrer avant de changer de passer
à autre chose sur instagram on la voit
regarder en train de ramasser des
billets ça a fait polémique
et pourtant vous allez voir c'est une
belle initiative voilà ça c'est sur
scène parce que sur instagram à la
poster que les billets on comprenait pas
et donc sachez que tous ces billets la
une sur scène on donne elle s'arrête
elle fait un polaroïd d'elle et puis
elle demande à des gens venir acheter de
polaroïd alors les gens jettent des
billets comme ça est celui qui s'est le
plus de billets par avec la photo est en
fait la photo l'argent va où guillaume
l'argent à l'association pour le malawi
vous savez absolument c'est assez rare
pays très pauvres d'afrique où elle a
adopté quatre petits-enfants quatre
enfants du malawi où il en avait déjà 2
qu'elle avait eu avec deux hommes
différents et à la quatre enfants du
malawi et c'est pour ces beaux draps
yake du convent on va on veut comme
c'est une bonne et c'était bon vin on va
ouvrir un petit peu la culture générale
le malawi qui est où me magali c'est un
pays africain
d'accord il sa 4e puis dimitrov